loin des tensions qui règnent à la
frontière entre l'ukraine et la russie
bendo d'options aux ateliers et aux
jeunes se sont établis ici dans ce coin
paisible de gatineau en fin de match les
normands des hommes puis par le site
ynet en ukraine pour un mariage
traditionnel c'est natalia qui a quitté
l'ukraine en premier il y à 22 ans
son mari aime tellement le québec qu'il
a écrit un livre sur sa terre d'accueil
en ukrainien et derrière la tranquillité
apparente l'inquiétude est bien réelle
je touche que manquer pour ça au
pcc s'est dit fier comme jeudi poutine
pour ouvrir le crâne quant au moment
d'une seule chose qui peut les pêcher
c'est la réaction de l'occident
déclenché peut-être le troisième guerre
mondiale
mais j'espère que non les parents de
jeunes par exemple sont trop vieux pour
être rapatrié au canada si vladimir
poutine lancent une attaque je dirais
que le pro de réponse de l'occident en
général très faible le couple
souhaiterait voir une réponse plus ferme
de justin trudeau avec entre autres
l'envoi d'armes au gouvernement de kiev
santoro ne peut pas se défendre les
hommes c'est le grenier de l'europe et
les états unis ont déjà commencé à
fournir de l'équipement militaire
d'anciens ambassadeurs de l'ukraine à
ottawa croit que le canada doit emboîter
le pas construire
une décision du gouvernement trop d'où
pourrait venir dans les prochains jours
en attendant plusieurs ministres ont
exprimé leur solidarité sur twitter un
soutien accueilli avec scepticisme par
cet ex passe des photos où on dit on y
avait une crainte mais sans freiner ou
très peu en forme de succès concrets
natalia et eugène sont moins cynique
apparaissent comme une arme alors on
doit parler on doit comme dispersée
l'information de tout ce qui se passe
car même si ces messages ne sont pas
suffisants ils sont au moins exprimer
librement une liberté d'expression qui
pourrait disparaître en ukraine
si l'invasion russe se concrétise et si
leur enceinte et radio-canada gatineau